opposers I love America it's been
perfect ever since day one when the
Pilgrims landed at Plymouth Rock and
immediately refused to bake a cake for
some gay Indians unreligious grouts I
love it here in America
but I've got to be honest sometimes what
I look around I don't recognize my
country anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
first up female Cox or as they call them
chickens there's nothing more American
than KFC you got Kentucky you got fried
and you got a weaker creatures blood on
your hands America well not anymore
KFC is developing a vegetarian fried
chicken a spokesperson says the offering
is aimed at healthy eaters vegetarian
fried chicken that's an oxymoron like
government efficiency or unflattering
picture of Eric Trump leave your recipe
alone KFC it's our president's favorite
thing to eat after cheeseburgers and
Paul Ryan's integrity I mean meatless
chicken come on that's not the America I
know am I even in America anymore
it sure does it feel like it you know
what maybe I'm not maybe I'm in some
other country like I don't know Finland
and I'm polishing Olympic hockey medals
with my friends Lena and Aleksandr go to
the public library because this country
has the highest rate of book borrowing
per capita before afternoon of hiking
through the seventy eight percent of the
country that's covered in forests while
the rest is yours
next up man's best friend statues
I love statues they're a great way to
commemorate American heroes who love
this country so much they waged war
against it but now some new statues are
coming to town New York City is now
launching the she built NYC campaign
first lady chirlane McCray says finding
a memorial or statue to instrumental
women in New York City is like going on
a scavenger hunt when there are no
representations of the women who built
this city women of all ethnicities the
message is that women's contributions
are worth less than men's hating what do
you mean you need more statues of women
you already have the tallest one she's
great she's holding a book she's
supposed to welcome everyone to the
country if you think about it the Statue
of Liberty is America's bitchy hostess
I'm sorry about our poor tired huddled
masses section is like so full you could
go wait at the bar it's a detention
center it's a cage so I guess this
organization is mad that there are
nearly a hundred fifty historical male
statues in New York and only five female
statues but that can't be true there are
so many statues of women I see them
everywhere always staring out of windows
that man
judging by cargo shorts wearing lingerie
in public some of them don't even have
heads
and none of them are my mom I never said
they were me come on more statues of
women what is this this isn't my country
what happened to the America I know and
love maybe I'm not there anymore maybe
I'm in Barbados and I'm dancing at the
crop / festival with a nearly naked and
bedazzled Rihanna and we're giggling
about the countries near 100% literacy
rate before we drunkenly sashay down to
one of the many beaches for a meal of
cuckoo when if I choke on flying fish
it's okay
because we haven't nationalized health
care next up The Incredibles 2 came out
last week and hot on its heels the PC
police at the New York Post published an
article called hey pervert stop staring
at elastic girls but now elastic girl is
the mum and personally I barely noticed
her I was too busy admiring what I would
look like with bleached hair but
apparently a lot of people noticed that
Elastigirl is a quote unquote thick
superhero queen
so what but we not allowed to sexualize
cartoon characters anymore
that's a proud of American tradition
from Betty Boop - Daphne - Rosie the
robot made sweet sweet Rosie
that's the thickest of them all just
look at that sexy maid outfit those
angry red eyes the sensual claw hands
that double guillotine mouth and listen
to her I could help you Miss Judy I'm
Wyatt the tape analysis whoo she nasty
look if we catch sexual ID cartoon
characters even doing honestly don't
feel like I'm in America I feel like I'm
in Hell floating down the river Styx
with some loser boat demon insisted I
pay him a fair no way dude this is a
damn robo and I don't even choose to
come aboard I'm keeping my 50 cents and
now I have to make small talk with
Stalin and that gorilla that stole sign
language the way this play sucks I can't
stand it anymore this is too much Chuck
Chuck
bring me back man tell me this is it
hell and then I'm still in the country I
love his US politics still dominated by
men yes but a record-breaking number of
women are running for office this year
what Chuck normally at the end of this
segment you give me some reassurance
that America is not changing to be
honest the country is changing there's
growing diversity movements like me - I
had a veggie burger for lunch and it was
okay okay
you're saying that not all change is bad
maybe I should try it
Chuck you're fired wait what the fight
continues the fight continues good you
hid down here with a real truth lies you
want to help me defeat the globalists
and stay on the inside click and
subscribe
and help me defeat them because
following me on my youtube channel makes
you a leader it tracks trust me